we talked earlier about there was a time
when you just got kind of stuck in this
place where you couldn't really move you
didn't want to do this or you didn't
want to do that and you didn't know it
was depression yep
you talked about what happened yeah so
when I started to understand what a
depression was there's a clinical
definition when you really get down to
it is you're unable to make a decision
to move either forward or backwards
where you're really stuck in this very
specific place and so when I first moved
to New York I didn't realize that I had
been going through such a depression
because I wasn't able to write I wasn't
able to I mean a play essay anything I
wasn't able to do anything and I also
wasn't able to make a decision about
what my life was about to look like and
so when I started to deal with that I
definitely decided to get with a
therapist and start really working
through the process about where I was
and where I was eventually trying to go
and I've been able to identify a lot of
like the decisions that I was making in
the president we're routing a lot of
stuff that I had done and dealt with in
the past like losing my job and trying
to prove to people that I had worthiness
even though something very valuable to
me was actually taken away and so one of
the things that the therapist said that
really began to transform me was one he
said nobody is responsible for your life
but you and how you engage and get back
to you is you do the things that you
want to do the things that you enjoy the
things that make you happy and through
that you will be able to kind of start
seeing the light at the end of the
tunnel and so that's when I started to
go to as much theater as I could in New
York and it was just like a seed that
had been watered you know where it was
like I was dead in my creative ability I
started to really flourish and start
coming up with the ideas and started to
see the definition of who I was and
there was just one specific play called
sunset baby written by Dominic Moore so
that I think really was just it really
defined me and my personal journey
because she was trying to just go get on
a flight and get away
and that's all I was ever trying to do
was kind of get away and escape the past
I said have embraced in the past and
using it as a fuel to create everything
in the present just kind of what I went
through and how I was able to get back
on the other side and fortunately I
haven't experienced that in a long time
sunset baby sunset baby and you saw that
in New York I saw that in New York at
the lab labyrinth theater it was
unexpected but it was such a great piece
of poetic work
it was just tremendous did you reach out
to the playwright no I never did it I've
never reached out and it's interesting
enough because I've met other writers
who know exactly who she is and so maybe
you know maybe the universe will align
and I'll be able to one day see your
look on her face and tell her hey this
play really helped you the journey that
I had internally so did it also healed
but then you also wanted to write plays
like that work that were affecting and I
understood that the what made it so
effective is that it came from a very
real place inside of her and again I
wasn't writing a place because I was
trying to hide so much of who I was from
the rest of the world I wasn't able to
authentically tell these really deep and
rich stories so once I started to be
okay with me and who I was I was able to
go out and start really telling stories
in a very authentic in a rich way and
while it not has not necessarily caught
on to the popular culture people that
have been able to witness my work have
been affected by it and that's what I'm
grateful for do you remember what I was
like to leave a theater after you saw
that like were you in one of these days
--is I was it was hard to get to that
theater too because that theater is like
not by the trams and I remember not one
not wanting to leave the theater I
didn't really want to leave the theater
so I just kind of remember sitting there
for just like a half second longer than
what I should have and then immediately
we went across the street and I just
wanted to just like regurgitate and just
talk about the piece and talk about the
journey and it's been so many amazing
place
I've seen in the New York so many
incredible plays and playwrights that
people probably would never see that
work staged but it's an incredible group
of writers and talent to pour from in
New York
you